avec ses 24 mille visiteurs en 2018
l'arboretum souhaite faire encore mieux
en 2019
et pour cela de nouveaux parcours ont
germé le premier est une véritable
randonnée de plus de 10 kilomètres de
long a sillonné en 4 5 heures ce
parcours permet de découvrir les
différentes ambiances au végétal et les
différents paysages et d'avoir un aperçu
des différentes collections qui sont
présentes dans l'arboretum et cela
débute fort avec la fameuse aller de
cèdre bleu qui prolonge les perspectives
à la française du parc de versailles
qu'ils ont défait de l'atlas ont été
plantés à partir de 1922 fait 800 mètres
de longueur et a priori c'est la plus
longue allée de cette double du monde
six jardiniers travaillent à l'année
dans l'arboretum pour entretenir les dix
mines arbres cette flore qui abrite
également une faune variée et riche
lors de la randonnée justement c'est
quelque chose que vous mettre en avant
c'est la vidéaste et naturel et lors de
la promenade qui fait tout le tour de
l'arboretum vous verrez forcément soin
des oiseaux des faisans et il ya
beaucoup de faisans ou bien des lièvres
ou bien des poules d'eau des canards
pour se rendre des pommiers ornementaux
au bois de l'ancienne pépinière un
chemin tracé par la tonte au milieu des
prairies et un système de balisage bien
connue des randonneurs les adeptes de la
balade familiale aussi ont leur nouveau
parcours consacré aux espèces
d'ile-de-france dans a voulu que ce soit
accessible aux familles donc aux enfants
et aux adultes
alors les panneaux il ya des choses à
dire mais l'idée c'est que les parents
puissent lire les panneaux avec les
enfants pour leur présenter les
différentes essences d'arbres mais aussi
quelques concepts écologiques des
concepts écologiques comme cet arbre
mort véritable biotope pour des espèces
souvent menacés par la tendance à
nettoyer les sous-bois de ces arbres
dont la vie est terminée
une partie du tronc et même d'écouter
les visiteurs peuvent s'amuser à compter
les cernes et déterminer l'âge de ce
chêne notre idée c'est de présenter la
biodiversité et de sensibiliser
sensibiliser le public à sa protection
et donc ya pas que la collection
d'arbres qui est intéressante à
chèvreloup il ya aussi l'idée de montrer
comment vivent les arbres et comment ils
sont associés dans la vie de la forêt
quarante six panneaux jonchent le
parcours ile de france 2 900 m de quoi
devenir incollable sur la vie végétale